here in germany the government is being
sued by an afghan worker who was left
behind when german forces withdrew from
the country
international troops pulled out of
afghanistan last summer germany had
pledged to help resettle more than 20
000 former local staff but only a
fraction have actually been brought to
germany now several german ngos are now
supporting the lawsuit of an afghan
teacher who argues germany is not
fulfilling its duty to protect its
former staff member against taliban
threats
for more on the story we can speak to
karl kopp who works for pro azul that's
an organization that is supporting this
legal case carl thank you for joining us
tell us more about this case and who
it's being brought by i mean who are
these afghans who've been left behind
these are different cases the several
afghan plaintiffs
worked in a police cooperation project
coordinated by the afghan ministry of
interior
and so they work on behalf of the german
government and the implementing partner
gets the
the society for international
cooperation the implementing partner of
the german government concerning this
project so they worked
for the german authorities
and they had a
in the field of police cooperation in
the field of teaching human rights
issues and so on they work all over the
country
and they after
taliban-sized kabul they are really in a
life-threatening situation and they are
left behind and they
appeal to the german authorities take us
in we are threatened physical
physically abused
please take us in and there was no
response and then they started suing the
german government
uh
to get the visa that's it
to get a lifeline and carl can you tell
us what is the german government saying
why have they not been able to ensure
these people's safety
okay there are two different aspects
one is uh concerning the local service
forces sometimes they have a freelance
contract and
maybe there is a german definition they
are not part of the rescue program
and we say okay the taliban
make no distinction whether you have
have a freelance contract or a static
contract
they are all threatened because they
work
for the german institutions so this is
one aspect the second aspect is there's
a very chaotic situation concerning the
registration the email registration
so maybe
one part of their
appeals
are in a limbo situation so we have a
double approach now
the legal strategy to sue the german
government to grant the visa
high speed
in a life-saving
manner and meanwhile the new government
the three strong women in different
uh ministry have a chance to solve the
cases and solve
the whole issue there is a protection
gap concerning definition of these
locals working for the kids it's about
it's about this
six seven persons but all together three
thousand persons who are still in the
limbo waiting desperately to get a
lifeline to get a visa to get an exit
strategy
that's it
thank you very much karl kopp from paul
azul thanks for that update of the
situation
thank you
you